il s'appelle kyle gordy et le pratiquer
un métier pour le moins insolite
cet américain de 30 ans et donneur de
sperme et il est déjà le père biologique
de 46 enfants et falaise
l'homme actuellement en tournée en
europe font gratuitement ses services à
toutes les femmes qui souhaiteraient
devenir maman si la plupart de ces dons
se font par insémination artificielle
lui arrive dans 10% des cas d'avoir une
relation sexuelle et le service après
vente est assurée puisque qu'elle gordy
prend toujours des nouvelles du bébé à
sa naissance vous trouveront là de quoi
faire enfin baisser le chômage
franchement c'est un gigolo des temps
modernes cyril alors il prend pas
d'argent mais c'est honteux quoi il fait
ça pour faire l'amour il se
trouve que sa philanthropie pan des
nouvelles y lâche pas les gens ici la
personne n'a envie plutôt de le faire de
façon traditionnelle il le fait et il
trompa d'argent s'est passé du
fétichisme à ce niveau là c'est plus
sexy schisme il fait ça parce que non
mais c'est pas normal qu on peut donner
du sperme à petite dose j'ai envie désir
pour aider quelques femmes ou voilà une
façon anonyme la plupart du temps mais
là clairement le mot fétichisme c'est la
première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit quand j'ai lu l'article
personnel après la messe et quand même
causé citadelle et mathieu et vous pas
du tout parce que vous êtes si on se
connaissait avant oui on s'était vus
rigueur dans tpm une ou deux fois on n'a
qu'à pas très performant l'autre comme
c'était prévu on avait beaucoup rigolé
c'est quoi ce jusqu'au but c'est un but
qui est 4e à paris y avait quoi une
vingtaine de pièces aux personnes dans
le bus c'est la première fois qu'on se
rencontre est tout à fait et on a
beaucoup rigolé on a beaucoup rigolé on
était là il y avait c'était une soirée
gay bus et
bus avance au bois peu rigole rien de vu
ça
le bus s'arrête et mais ça avance ça
avance et plus tu recules le bus avant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sens les sondages
étaient jusqu'à la fin de la soirée
ouais c'est là qu'on s'est rencontré et
de trouver charmant haïtiens qui on a eu
l'idée après pour tp des écoles on avait
bien rigolé bonne complicité ont ce
tacle est un peu on avait bien on se
taquinait bien la patte avec plus de
chemise c'est assez classique permet de
dire oui
c'est quand il a mis au vote de son slip
sont vos yeux
c'est le cadeau que j'ai fait pour leur
opposer les pmp vitamine c est mon but
serait pas très bien pas plus dans le
bus à la voile a lancé me dire pourquoi
on a bientôt s'ils voulaient venir non
merci drôle
non franchement j'ai ma voiture
avec personne peut descendre tanguay au
début du mois vous regardez pas chez moi
j'ai mon véhicule
ok